hi everyone i'm shashfort and i'm going
to talk about
sharp threshold rates for random codes
this is joint work with venkat guru
swami
jonathan michael nicholas fresh and mary
wooters
and i hope the joke in the subtitle
isn't too updated
first some quick background about eric
wrecking codes
a is trying to send a message to b over
a channel but because of
noise parts of this message may be
corrupted the way to deal with this
is that only a certain subset of things
that b can receive
are actually valid so if b receives a
message which is
invalid it corrects the error by
assuming that a meant is sent
the closest valid message to what we
actually received
formally a code c of block length n over
an alphabet sigma
is just a subset of all length hand
springs over sigma
the rate r of a code c is just the log
of its size divided by its block length
and there's a trade-off between the
error tolerance of a code and its rate
for example if the rate is one then
every length hand string over sigma is a
valid
code word so no error tolerance is
actually possible
we will think of sigma as f cubed for q
constant
n is going to infinity and the error
will be adversarial
so a random code is a subset of sigma to
the n which is chosen in such a way that
every point in sigma to the n
is included in c with the appropriate
probability
so that the expected rate of the code is
r random objects are often
important in dorics because they often
have
ideal properties with high probability
the same is true for error correcting
codes you may have seen that random
codes are used in the proof of classical
coding terms such as shannon's noisy
channel coding theorem
and understanding random code deeply is
just a very basic question in
combinatorics and error correction codes
and they can be
easy to analyze so it's a good starting
point for understanding other kinds of
codes better
one place where people may have seen
random codes before
is the list decoding capacity theorem a
code c
is bliss decodable if for all x and f q
to the n
the ball of radius b around x
intersected with the code
has size strictly less than l
pictorially what this means is you have
a code which is just a bunch of points
if you move a ball of radius p around
the space
you can never catch l or more
points of the code within the ball
so the list decoding capacity theorem
says something really interesting
it says that if you want a code which is
this decodable
for reasonably small list sizes so l is
kind of small
then the rate of the code has to be less
than one minus hq of b
in fact if the rate is even slightly
more then your list has to necessarily
be large
the way you show that there are in fact
codes which are list decodable with
small list sizes at rates slightly less
than one minus hq of p
is just by bounding the probability that
a random code fails to be less decodable
using a union
valve in this way the property of not
being list decodable with smaller list
sizes
undergoes a phase transition for random
codes that is
below a certain rate this probability is
close to
zero and even slightly above that rate
it quickly jumps to one
because in fact no code above that rate
is less decodable with smallest sizes
more generally we might ask how common
are these things
transitions for properties of random
codes we might care about and can we
understand them
let's say for binary random codes if we
fix
l equals 3 is there a threshold
such that if the rate of random code is
even slightly below that threshold then
it is b comma 3 list decodable with high
probability
and if the rate is even slightly above
that threshold then it is
not p common 3 list decodable with high
probability
in order to characterize and understand
these phase transitions we need some
definitions
we say a code property is monotone
increasing if given a code
c satisfying p it holds that every code
c
prime such that c is a subset of c prime
also satisfies b
you can quickly check that not being
list decodable
is such a property because if your code
is already not list decodable with a
small list size then
adding more code words is definitely not
going to make it less decodable
for property b we refer to its threshold
rate
as the largest rate for which a random
code
satisfies that property with probability
less than or equal to a half
and we say that a property is sharp if
the probability that a random code
satisfies that property
jumps from 0 to 1 over an arbitrarily
small transition window as n goes to
infinity
we're going to write these definitions
out in
notation and feel free to pause the
presentation at this point to go over
that
but i'm going to skip ahead so
the informal outline of our paper is
that we characterize the threshold rate
for a large class of properties which
are also sharp
the way we do this is by noticing that
many natural code properties are
satisfied
if any one of a certain number of
minimal sets of code words are present
in the code
for example a code is not pl list
decodable
if it contains any l code words
which lie in a ball of radius p because
then these l code words are witnessed to
the code's non-disk decodability
we group all of these possible minimal
sets of code words would specify
a property into sets of types
then a property is satisfied by a random
code with high probability
if a set of code words with such a type
is present in the code with high
probability
we later defined some metric properties
which include all kinds of things that
coding through us care about like list
decoding list recovery
and show that every symmetric property
has a sharp
threshold for random codes and we also
characterize this threshold
since we are often going to be talking
about tuples of code words appearing in
a code all together
it makes sense to view them as matrices
here we have three code words b1
b2 and b3 and we're going to view them
as an n by 3 matrix
the columns of this matrix are code
words
before we state and understand the main
theorem we need another couple of
definitions
the first one is that of types so here's
our matrix of three code words b
in b prime i've interchanged the middle
two rows of b
resulting in a new matrix of three
different code words
in b double prime i've interleaved the
rows
of b with each other and i have another
matrix of three
new code words and the point is all
three of these matrices
have the same type formally the type
is just the empirical distribution over
the rows of the matrix
in all three of these matrices the row
alpha alpha beta
occurs with probability half and the row
gamma beta beta
occurs with probability half and no
other row appears at all
they all have probability zero we can
say that two matrices
are the same type if they are row
permutations of each other
another definition we need is that of
histogram types
now again i have our matrix of three
code words b
and here i've not only interchanged the
center two rows with each other
but i've also individually permuted
their indices in b double prime
i have interleaved the rows of b with
one another
and i've also individually permuted
every row
with a different column permutation the
point is in a histogram type
the probability assigned to any row only
depends on its histogram
so the rows with two alphas and a beta
make up for probability half for this
matrix and the rows with two betas and a
gamma
make up for probability half in the rows
of this matrix
and it doesn't really matter within the
row what order
the two alphas and the beta or the two
betas and a gamma appear
we say that two matrices b and b prime
are the same
histogram type if there is a permutation
pi mapping the rows of b
onto the rows of b prime and for all i
row i of b and the row i i of b
prime have the same elements as sets
so here's our main theorem stated a
little informally
suppose b is a symmetric property and we
haven't defined that yet
but the only thing that you should keep
in mind at this point is that
this includes a lot of properties that
coding carers care about like
list decoding list recovery average
radiuses decoding and so on
and this property is defined by the
inclusion
of a matrix among a set of whose type
lies among a set of types t
then if r star is one minus
the maximum curie shannon entropy
of all the types in d divided by b
then for any epsilon greater than 0
a random code of rate slightly more than
r star
satisfies this property with probability
almost 1
and a random code of rate slightly less
than r star
satisfies b with probability almost zero
so our star is in fact the threshold
rate
for these properties and these
properties are all
sharp so let's try to see
the proof of this theorem so we'll first
do a very simple lower bound on r star
using
just the union bound so suppose c
is a random code of radar over f q to
the n
given b which is a matrix of little b
code words the probability that all the
columns of b
appear in c as codewords is just q to
the negative
n times b times quantity one minus r
this is because every column has to
appear
has to appear in the code independently
of each other
then the probability that c contains a
matrix of the same type as b
which we call beta is just this funny
expression by simply using the union
bound
and if you look at this carefully you'll
notice that this says if
r is less than one minus hq of beta
divided by b
then this probability goes to zero
so the code does not contain any matrix
with the same type as b
with high probability so if p
is a property defined by containing a
matrix with type in t
which is a set of types then r star has
to be
at least one minus the maximum over
all types tau in t of hq of tau divided
by b
and the question we'd like to answer is
is this tight
as in could this threshold rate r star
be any higher than this lower bound that
you compute by just using the union
bound
and i'm going to say something very
imprecisely here um
only for people who followed previous
work by mashayev at all from fox 2020
which asks similar questions about
properties and their thresholds
for random linear codes and
the only thing to notice is that if the
property we were talking about was say
list decodability of random linear codes
then the answer would be no and in fact
this threshold rate
can be higher than what you compute by
just using the union value
however for random completely random
codes
we have this really cool result which
says that
if you use the use the second moment
method you can show that for a histogram
type
tau a random code of rate r star
which is 1 minus hq of tau divided by b
plus epsilon must contain a matrix
of histogram type tau with probability
almost 1.
so if b is a property which is defined
by a set of histogram types then the
lower bound computed on the threshold
rate using the union bound
is actually tight for completely random
codes
however histogram types don't define
properties like
list decodability so this definition is
a little too restrictive for us to get
really cool results from the coding
theory perspective
so we do a little extra work to get
there
so to summarize what we have so far
we know that if p is a property defined
by containing a matrix would type in t
then the threshold rate is at least
greater than
this expression also if t
has the additional property that it
contains a histogram type
tau prime which attains the maximum
entropy amongst all types in d
then in fact we know that r star is
exactly this expression and we've
managed to characterize the threshold
rate and show that the property
is in fact sharp so that's where
we come up with the notion of a
symmetric property i'm not going to say
this formally in the dock because it is
slightly technical and
needs a lot of definitions so feel free
to like look at the paper and
see what a symmetric property is but we
basically show
that for symmetric enough sets of types
d
it holds that there is always a
histogram type the
tau prime in d which attains the maximum
entropy amongst all the types in d
properties defined by such sets of types
are symmetric properties and they
include a list decodability
this recovery average radius is
decodability and all these things that
go interiors care about
and for all of these properties our star
that we computed from the union bound
is in fact the threshold rate and these
properties are sharp in the way that
we've defined the word sharp
so our full results are a little more
than what we talked about in this
little presentation but we saw that we
were able to characterize the threshold
rate for symmetric properties and these
properties included a lot of things we
would
traditionally care about as coding
theorists
we also give analytic estimates for the
threshold rate for noisy list recovery
in our paper the reason that we do this
for noisy list recovery is that it
contains
list decoding and you know all of these
properties as
it implies the results for those
properties as well so it's a more
general version
we provide an algorithm for efficiently
computing the threshold rate for list
recovery up to any small additive error
we precisely compute the threshold rate
for p commentary list decoding for
binary random codes
remember this was the motivating
question that we asked at the very
beginning like could we even answer
this like very simple question very
precisely for random codes
and we can and we get that the threshold
rate is in fact this
um this expression immediately may not
mean so much
but it is kind of cool because we also
did
the a similar computation for random
linear codes
and for p comma 3 list decoding of
binary random linear codes we get
a different threshold than for
completely random codes
so it's nice that our methods can get
very fine-grained information
and even precisely pinpoint such
differences between random and random
linear codes
and then we also precisely compute the
threshold rate
for a random code to be a perfect
hashing code which is also a special
case of list recovery but it's still a
cool result that people have
asked about in previous work so
that's it i hope you enjoyed this little
talk and that you'll
have a chance to look at our paper and
thank you for your time